[Music]
our little girls growing up so fast and
things couldn't be
better
what is
that okay let's clear it all out it's
demo
day demo wait what's happening who are
you
people what's going
on wait wait you
can't hey hey what are you doing all
right she's all set that was what
orange who made the console orange do I
look orange I didn't touch it orange is
not my color not
me hello oh my gosh I'm anxiety where
can I put my stuff a new emotion wow oh
I'm sorry we wanted to make such a good
first impression what do you mean
[Music]
we
w
[Music]
oh
oh hi there little
[Music]
buddy you hungry little
guy you want a little
[Music]
more
and that's how I adopted
John okay now have you ever been with a
play Don't e oh please no ow it's so hot
it's really hurting
ow deserve
[Music]
to say when never John bury me and
cheese I apologize in advance the eating
you're about to see will not be pretty
and if you have young children this
would be a good time for them to leave
the room you never
nobody hey Junior this is my father you
ever jumped a train I've never jumped
here's I stop really
where OD you think he'd see that coming
let's get it I deserve to be somebody
[Music]
me we are the
12 each with a unique power meant to
protect this
world but we need you for what's
[Music]
coming are you ready to begin your
training don't PR what you can't teach
don't talk what you can't walk okay hold
on you'll be faster I know who I am when
I know where I land stronger than most
humans wait wait wait hey hey
no I'm more powerful than you could
possibly
imagine I'm going to stay in
the wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't so what are you my
sidekick no not
[Music]
exactly
mess with a tiger you get the claws what
that's not a thing yes it is no it isn't
no one says that tiger
[Music]
do
mahito
so you made
it mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place Jo us I just hope he stays
safe save me save me my oh what exactly
are
you your mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lot but I have to
see I'm looking for someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now
[Music]
AR you and I aren't mens or Allies
kid don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready you see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done a gray Heron once told me that all
gray herand are liar so is that the
truth or a lie a lie
truth we have to be a lie
[Music]
too we are going to make boy band
history tonight bro you're making baby
Branch nervous I feel like I'm going to
barf and pass out and pee your pants all
at once how' you you know give it up for
[Applause]
[Music]
bro you suck my exquisitly chiseled rock
hard abs and I quit franch we're out of
sink we've gone from Boys to Men and now
there's only one direction for us to go
the back streets bye see you
later granch what oh hey are you all
right you're smiling and crying at the
same time it kind of looks like it's
hurting your face
it does hurt my
face baby Branch I'm John Dory branches
brother what ow former brother drama
call me
Dingle it's hard to say I'm sorry a
brother is a friend who can never leave
you it's the strongest bond in the world
I would kill to have a sibling to sing
with check out your old outfits puffy
jackets pcell necklaces denim tuxedo did
you have frosted tips we'll get you you
were so cute I love it it was an ERA
tragic bran our brother is being held
captive in a diamond prison there's only
one thing that's powerful enough to
shatter Diamond the perfect family
Harmony should we be letting a baby
drive I have procured my learner's
permit who was a Dy McMahon's face the
better question is are you a
narc who comes
there we're here looking for our
[Music]
brother oh my gosh h
my name is Viva it is so fantastic
amazing to see other
TRS did you just braid my hair you're
welcome it looks so good I love it is
your dad King peepe uh yeah poppy I'm
your sister my what hey man am I the
only one without a long lost sibling
this is your second chance with your
brothers
Branch b b maybe a smaller diaper if
this diaper was any smaller I could
taste it I know you think it's risky and
maybe it is but it'll be worth it
family's always worth it WR I ever I
can't believe this is really
[Music]
happening we still got it looks like
your Band-Aid aren't behind
you let me take
you I'm going to make it kiss the
tonight
[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
danin what is this place we are
completely lost was you
mother a
that is not your mother look it we're
trying to get to Jamaica it alls
simp don't worry Chum's gotcha so listen
chump what did you just call me sorry I
thought your name was chump yeah chump
yeah that's my name what right so listen
chump what did you just call me I'm
sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
[Music]
what this isn't about migration it's
about Adventure W wo wo wo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dang it's you with laange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we
is when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm kidding
where am
[Music]
I go go
go it is time to take the next step on
your journey I'm not going to be the
Dragon Warrior anymore you will advance
the spiritual leader of The Valley Of
Peace inner
peace
inner peace keep your surf off my
turf dinner please dinner with peas in
AES glaze this is not working at
[Music]
all tyong big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the Great Dragon
Warrior who's that the most powerful
shape-shifting sorceress the chameleon
how do I find this the chameleon I'm
going to lead you right to her front
door it was against an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our
own what is this place the best Crooks
and criminals live here you're a wanted
criminal you sound surprised is it
surprising now you kids be careful of
those fireworks
Works silence makes our tummies tingle
why should we help you we we take down
the chameleon together being the Dragon
Warrior it's who I am SC what do I know
about being a spiritual leader what is
it you're holding a cookie you were
chosen to become something more than you
already
[Music]
are how should we do this quick and
painless yeah yeah or slow and painful
slow and
painful you finally met your match
chameleon We're Not So Different you and
I stand back I'm going to kick my
butt Nation Army couldn't hold
me illumination legendary villain is
back in an all new short you wouldn't
happen to know how to get out of here
would you bye
[Music]
Moon don't miss Moon only in theaters
with migration this Christmas there's a
whole world we've been missing out on
what is that do stuck a laange it's you
with larange on top migration plus
Vector rated
BG look at this place in Emin the sun is
shining everybody's out there having fun
makes you want to get out there and joy
them doesn't it well I'll see
[Applause]
you now do not forget you are the help
they are the guest your spritzer has
arriv ride h of you got to get out of
your shell buddy come on Army I'm not
like these other crabs I don't I don't
throw my claws in the
air I don't wave them like I just don't
care wakey this is for your own good
army
but ask go to dance what you got moov
girl what did you say to me no no no no
no that wasn't me that was uh him him
who me me me oh he's so
cute hey look
out
aren where are you aren how far are we
from the ocean in in Crab LS I don't
know maybe a million this may be the
furthest away from my mother I've ever
been wooo it feels amazing girl have you
lost your
mind oh this my
jam How You Like Me
Now are you you know lost and afraid for
my life other than that can't complain
come on open your eyes I liked it better
when they were shut what are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]
kid it is good to see you out of the
house
Ary what do you think they'll think of
us oh
snap are you finished yet c crab cuz
you're standing and not drinking
water
when our world is
threatened one team is ready to launch
did he say launch uh no I said launch
the Manor's heading straight for
us get down
W it's giving off some kind of
energy I didn't do it no way this
September I think we got
superpowers and that's why I wear a hard
hat I got the power I feel the need for
super speed I'm a wrecking ball
surf look at your
paws great now the clumsy puff shoots
Fireballs out of his paws a new breed of
Heroes superpowers are real hits the big
screen we're going to need a new name
for ourselves how about the PAW Patrol
but more but just a little bit extra yes
how
about the mighty pups I got
the those should be my superpowers
coming in hard I'm going to take them
one by
one oh my goodness I can
talk I have so much to say give me that
it's showtime well well well Humdinger
he looks different than I
remember all right puppy play time's
over when you go up against one of us
you go up against all of us let's
go now that we're super I'm never going
to get to sleep well you're probably
more tired than
you you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
3 2 1 Asha I'm here I'm here just one
second let me catch my breath Once Upon
a Time St Roos us the most Magical
Kingdom founded by a king with the power
to grant wishes you are their handsomest
most beloved King you're right I am a
handsome king I'm so nervous N I think
I'm going to explode my best friend the
king's Apprentice my mouth drooping I
feel like it's
trooping ASA come with me the wishes of
Rosas wow people give their wishes to me
and I grant the wishes I am sure are
good for Rosas some of these will never
be granted not some most they deserve
more than I decide what everyone
deserves so I look up at the stars to
guide me I wish and throw CAU to every
warning
sign oh you spoil us with your magic I
didn't do it
what last night I made a wish on a star
ah and the star
[Music]
[Applause]
answered I'm talking I am talking who
knew my voice voice would be this low I
believe I have just been threatened who
would dare threaten
you I have no response to that so I look
there is a traitor amongst us find
Asha every it's a dead end with unsanded
mahogany oh good find Valentino my butt
found
it I started this I have to finish it
so I make this wish what are you hiding
nothing to we live and nobody what is
going on in there okay ladies or Wings
can't fly but your voices
can everyone ready okay here we go that
is Maurice the Great Tiger Warrior and
that is Junior his son the little tiger
Warrior over there is Patricia and that
is Miguel and there is the brains of the
bunch it's me Gilbert our mission if we
choose to accept it is to come to the
help of any animal who needs it all
right Betty by great tiger Warriors need
their sleep too and it's not as if bad
guys are going to come and attack Us in
the
night tonight begins a brand new era for
the jungle tonight history will be
Rewritten the jungle is covered with a
dangerous substance that if it comes
into contact with water will destroy all
vegetation I got to have a pee
pee what can we do about it well uh we
need an antidote that will save the
jungle it can only be found in one place
and it's far far away it's one of the
most dangerous places on Earth Angelus
come on how bad can it
[Music]
be hi there friend can you help
us oh boy Migel nasty
Panda you have to stop them understood
yes yes we did it
Yori wow this is a perfect little boat
come on we've got a jungle to save here
we
go when the storms come the jungle will
be transformed into a desert oh no no
don't worry Gilbert we'll help you yep
and we'll do in St someone stop that t
you're forcing me to pull out all the
stops
[Music]
Arnold yep I knew it we're going to
fight pay attention fool you're about to
see what it means to be a hero you're
the only one who can save me I can't
take any more pies in the face I'm tired
of being rescued
I want to do the
rescuing I'm done with
your are you going to tell me what
you're up to I am going on a quest to
make something of my life I gave him 45
minutes
tops I know you you're the dude from the
play who keeps catching p in the face
I'm DJ Doggy
Dog there's something seriously wrong
with this
guy ha why are you smiling we've got to
save the baby raccoons DJ everyone loves
baby
raccoons I can't go res them the plan is
to improvise that's not a plan
onward it
[Music]
wet your imagination makes you move
mad a mighty
whale
this was a bad
idea I'm your friend grab my hand and
trust
me DJ doy thr Rhymes you catch if we rap
batt I'll win the match when I see your
turn table I always
SC
fore
[Music]
spee
for nah
[Music]
forent
nightly night what's up
roomie get ready it's Christmas Eve have
you been good last year not exactly
naughty but definitely gross for the
naughtiest have I ever shed you
wrong a bunch of times nicest what could
be better than being snowed in with your
family for the
holidays Limpus I think my freckles
might have frost bite do not make eye
contact Christmas ever read about this
family that got Snowden and to survive
they had to eat each other
streaming on Disney plus Del friend is
one of Santa's most important Scouts
it's
aive
Ry come on Diary of a Wimpy Kid
Christmas Cabin Fever streaming on
Disney
[Music]
plus Merry Christmas Gotham City in
breaking news Gotham is officially
crying free as Batman continues to clean
it
up Dad I'm ready to be a superhero like
you woo
woohoo Merry Christmas
kiddo my own utility belt which should
only be used in case of a bat emergency
oh come on dad I'm not a baby hey I
never said you were a baby emergency
call for help my precious little baby is
in
danger it's the Justice League sorry
Damen I got to go shall I assume we did
not see the bat Razer I like it totally
UPS my intimidation game you have donut
crumbs in your intimidation
games I promise I'll be back before
Christmas oh man I'm the worst dad
ever Jingle Bells backman smells robing
Len egg Joker oh how I want to make this
a very special Christmas Eve and what
better way to do it than by stealing
Christmas I have to show Dad I can
handle myself w oh it's a bit saggy well
that one just leaves nothing to the
imagination dad made me a bat
suit
awesome wait until they get a load of
me you don't have what it takes to be a
superhero I can do this I'm saving
Christmas all right which one of you
gave a little kid
explosives really want foras allow me to
break the ice little Batman everybody in
here what do you say need a wing
man more like a sid
[Music]
kick most of you you are aware that you
live in reality parallel to many
versions of your Universe I've gathered
you all to save your
world that does not look good you got
that
right the threat is
real I was on one of the Earths that was
swallowed by this wave well who we have
here I come from a parallel Earth we
look down on super
villains welcome our newly formed team
of Heroes the Justice
[Applause]
League drained of power from
them thank you Justice
League something's about to happen
something
major I am Harbinger this is the thing
yeah I figured you each possess the
skills strength and speed to save your
Universe Great Scott what's happening
the universe it's all Vanishing
look this is it I won't let you go is it
as bad as it looks yes 5 4 3 2
[Music]
1 what on
Earth we need a plan Tony can we liven
it up Fredy drop a beat
yes nice Shield cap you too
cap you dance but of course Let's Dance
for
smash who are you I'm the collector
behold my
collection when you get to be as big a
deal as I am it's all about about rare
one of a kind but it's still not enough
that's why I've decided to collect
Avengers take
[Music]
them anyone have any ideas we need
someone with special skills no not that
guy he's the best at what he does and
what he does isn't very
nice guess I'm not going to get to eat
my
lunch Mom's Diner that's just adorable
it's probably a death trap oh
boy activating scan and sword functions
two animals excuse
me we're going to build our way
out it's time to collect a little
payback
now you are going to be impressed by
this
[Music]
door buddy uh-oh I overdressed ah better
change no no Riv
it
nice making friends takes time but he's
always on his
own I wonder who this one is for
hello rabbit would you like to play with
me based on the Beloved tale wise horse
what does real
mean being real isn't about how you're
put
together when a child loves you with all
of their
heart then you become real celebrate the
magic of friendship as it comes to life
I'd like to become real one day if the
boy loves you then then you will when
children love you they do it with all of
their hearts leave me behind
never if there is a more beautiful
feeling I do not know
it the velvetine
rabbit
yeah
woohoo bubble bubble spill the tea show
me the catchiest fish in the
sea baby
shark baby shark
[Music]
him William do you swear to be my best
friend forever in sickness and in Kel
I
hi for the first time in Fisher baby the
sharks are moving to Chomp City we're
moving we're not going to be neighbors
anymore baby shark is starving wait me
in a major ocean picture the sights The
Sounds the
smells City Life we're living it hey I'm
swimming here try to think of this as a
new adventure it's dorana shello sign my
tentacles sign my tee your sign me chest
who
me once I steal Baby Shark Song I will
Ru the ocean with my music I must be the
catchiest fish in the
sea Gilly how many times do I I'm sorry
I can't help it your laugh is infectous
this December Stana is a pop starfish
super villain and she's captured
William this fish is on a mes I'm going
to need some powerful backup to save his
bestie William and all the resty GE her
up every fishy okay
let's do it so don't give
up
you
swimsational good luck you got
this WOW anything can
happen you know for a moment there I
thought we were being too much same baby
shark's big movie dive in with your
family December 8th streaming on
Paramount
[Music]
Plus
oh
no it's me Steve herle I just want this
holiday season to be the best thing can
be oops I want everything to be perfect
for the big guy when he arrives now who
wants to head to the mall they're
lighting up the giant Christmas tree ow
what he said maybe there's a way to
spread even more holiday cheese ah I
think I've got it make a good point I
built something to help spread a little
of that holiday cheer woo woo yes I'm
showing everybody that I got it spr the
holiday spirit without making mistakes
you've gamified being in the holiday
spirit yes 7 points oh no no I do not
like this idea
points oh
no you built engin powerered
[Music]
reindeer stop this thing take us back to
the
right
[Music]
now did I do
that hold on I can fix this no don't fix
anything want to go fix the holidays
yes you might be a little awkward goofy
a bumbling butter finger clutch I was
going to say eager but we all know your
heart is in the right place as long as
you care about the people around you
you're officially helping me spread
holiday
cheer dashing through the snow on a city
bus
[Music]
[Laughter]
nope